لا تزالوا تداعيات الضربه التي استهدفت
منشاه عسكريه بمدينه اصفهان قبل ايام
مستمره فبعد ان تذوق نظام طهران مراره
المسيارات في الضربه الاخيره اتهم نظام
الملالي في ايران كلا من اوكرانيا
والاكراد وامريكا واسرائيل بالتورط في
الهجوم مستشار فريق التفاوض النووي
الايراني محمد مرندي هدد اوكرانيا
بالصواريخ وطائرات المسيره واسلحه ايرانيه
مختلفه وذلك ردا على تصريحات لاحد
المستشارين رئيس الاكرانيا
بهجوم لطائرات المسيرته اسرائيليه على
مدينه اصفهان وقال المسؤول الايراني
مثل تلك الحماقه على حد تعبيره وكان
المستشار الاوكرانين بخير كتب في تغريده
بعض الضربه قائلا ليله متفجره في ايران
اوكرانيا
نظرتكم هذا التحذير لم يستطع تفسيره
المراقبون وهل هو يعني اعلان مسؤوليه هذا
الهجوم ام مجرد شماته بسبب ضربات مسيرات
ايران في اوكرانيا
بالقول ليله متفجره في ايران اوكرانيا
حذرتكم وايران تهددها بعواقب
التوتر الخيم على العلاقات بين ايران
اوكرانيا خلال الاشهر الماضيه
لمساعدتها في عمليتها باكرانيا
[موسيقى]
في ضربه اصفهان الاخيره
نناقش هذا الملف معه ضيوفينا من كيف
الدكتور الكسندر بوغمولوف مدير المعهد
الوطني الاوكراني للدراسات الاستراتيجيه
ومنها امستردام يعقوب سعيد الباحث في شان
الايراني اهلا بكم
واسمح لي ان ابدا مع الدكتور بكم لوف
دكتور في الواقع بينما اصابع الاتهام تتجه
بعد ضربه اصفهان لاسرائيل وربما امريكا
تاتي التصريحات الاوكرانيه لتعبر عن
سعادتها بهذه الضربه تلتقطتها ايران
السؤال ما مصلحه كاف في اعلان او في
التصريح بهذا المعنى
بصراحه صحيح
انه اصبح الطيران هي خليفه
درجه الرئيسيه والعراقيين والسعوديه يعني
والدول الخليج وكذلك هي خليفه من روسيا
اخر حربها ضد اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
عن
المزاج يعني تعبر
يعني عنا يعني همم فكل الناس متفاعلين
يعني بالنسبه لهذه الحركه اما بالنسبه
للمسؤوليه ما همم احنا ما تاخذنا لمسؤوليه
علينا فهذا من الغباء الايراني كذلك
الارتباك دليل الارتباك الايراني لانه
لارانيين لحد الان ولا يعني يعرفوا ماذا
حصل
عن سعادتها كما قلت حضرتك بهذه العمليه
همم استاذ يعقوب ايران التقطت هذه
التصريحات يعتبرت بان اوكرانيا عدوه بانها
همم تتحمل المسؤوليه مع مجموعه اخرى من
العناصر في ضربه ما الذي تريده ايران
لا اعرف مدى جديه هذا الموضوع لانه
بالتالي يعني اسرائيل هي قادره واثبتت
بانها مرارا وتكرارا قادره على اختراق
الاجهزه الامنيه الى قد يمهد او يهيئ
الظروف داخليا وخارجيا لرد ايراني
يمكن ان نقول له بالمحدود متمثل بتنفيذ
فيما يتعلق بالمعارضه الكرديه لانه اشار
ايضا المعارضه الكرديه على مقرات المعارضه
الكرديه بشكل محدود ولكن ايضا قد تذهب
ايران اكثر من ذلك وذلك من خلال يعني الرد
على اوكرانيا بتقديم صواريخ بالستير
المزيد من المسيرات بشكل علني هذه المره
لموسكو واتصور ذلك قد يؤدي الى تصعيد خطير
يعني في المنطقه لان هذه المره صواريخ نحن
راينا بان المسيرات الايرانيه لعبت دورا
كبيرا داخل اوكرانيا حتى ساهمت في ارتكاب
يعني مجاز الحرب داخل اوكرانيا بحق
المدنيين ايضا استهدفت يعني البنيه
التحتيه الاوكرانيه لذلك البلاستيقه تلعب
دور اكبر اذا فعلا تم تسليمها الى الجانب
الروسي
وهل تتفق معه بان ايران قد تصاعد همم
باتجاه همم توفير مسيرات همم اخرى لروسيا
بالنسبه للكلام يعني الوارد يعني من قبل
الحكومه الايرانيه حاليا فهو دليل انه هم
ناويين طبرير يعني همم تزويدهم يعني
المعدات العسكريه الروسي يعني بهذه
الطريقه
ولكن حضرتك مع القائل ولكن دكتور
صحيح صحيح
بالمناسبه يعني في ايران يعني ضد النظام
الفاشل المجرم
ستستغل هذه التصريحات كما قال الاستاذ
يعقوب لترد او انها قد تبرر بان هناك اكثر
من عنصر يمثل عدوا لها وبالتالي مع توسع
همم هذه الدول فهي تلتزم الصمت كما
التزمته قبل
احتمال يعني كل احتمالين مطروح وارد يعني
هناك ضغط يعني هناك
العمليات عسكريه هي عمليه ليست سهله
بالمناسبه
الاوكرانيا ليس بوسع راحت تنظيم مثل هذه
العمليات عندنا حاجه مباشره لانه احنا في
احتكاك مباشر مع دور روسي
حاجه لتوسع الصراع الى الخارج يعني
بالمناسبه
نحن يعني فعلا يعني فرحانين انه تعرض
المنشات العسكريه الاورانيه الايرانيه لكن
انا يعني بصراحه استانس يعني همم وجوده اي
عنصر
مكون يعني في هذه العمليه انما على ارجع
هناك همم هناك معارضه داخل ليها وليست فقط
الاقرارات هناك منظمات مختلفه هناك همم
يعني رغم الشعب جديد جدا ضد الحكومه
الايرانيه فاروق اي شيء واضح وكذلك هناك
امكانيات يعني واسعه لدى اسرائيل واسرائيل
لا هي اهتمام وخاصه مع الحكومه الجديده
الاسرائيليه ف- اا اي شيء غير مستثره يعني
بالنسبه همم
يعقوب لماذا منذ قليل رجحت بان يكون الرد
الايراني هو رد همم
عسكري او رد بتوفير مسيرات لماذا لا تعتقد
بان ايران قد تؤجل هذا الرد كما اجلته من
قبل على اثر اما استهدفات او حتى اختيالات
لاكبر قادتها
بيكون تاكيد انا لا اتوقع بين الرد يعني
سوف يكون موجه الى اسرائيل مثلا في هذه
الحاله ولكن هم نحن راينا من التصريحات
الايرانيه اتهمت القوى المعارضه الكرديه
بانها مهدت الطريق او ساهمت بادخال هذه
المسيارات يعني لا اعرف اسرائيل التي هربت
اطنان من الوثائق البرنامج النووي لا يصب
عليه ادخال مسيرات صغيره الحجم لايران ولا
تصورهم بحاجه الى هذه القوى الكرديه اللي
اتدخل مع انه لا يعني لا استبعد هذا
السيناريو ولكن لا اتصور بانهم بحاجه لذلك
لذلك هم همم تحدثوا بهذه التصريحات وتتصور
لي الظروف يعني توجيهي ضربات داخل المناطق
المقرات الكرديه في كردستان العراق وهذا
اللي يعني قد تكون له رسائل لقاعدتهم
الشعبيه المحدوده الداخليه وكذلك من
الاشاكن بالخارج بينهم قاموا بالرد على
ذلك اما فيما يتعلق باكرانيا فتصور بانه
بالامر يعني معروف انه ايران همم دع
الجانب الروسي بالمسيرات وان لم تعلن عن
ذلك معلومه اعلنوا بانهم قالوا انهم فعلا
سلموا هذه المسيرات ولكن هذه كانت قبل
الحرب اي بمعنى ادق بانه ايران يعني لديه
تجربه في هذا المجال ولا يمكننا ان نستثني
انه ايران تقوم بدعم المزيد من المسيرات
المشكله الاكبر هي ليست بالمسيرات المشكله
الاكبر بالصواريخ البالستيه في الحقيقه لا
اشار الى هذا التصريح لانهم لا يستبعدوا
ان يقدموا صواريخ بالستيه تصور هذا سوف
يكون له رد كبير على الجانب الايراني لانه
همم الصواريخ البالستيه داخل الاوكرانيا
في ظل هذه الظروف بالنسبه الاوروبيين
بالنسبه للامريكان هو خط احمر لانه سوف
يلعب دور كبير داخل الحرب الاوكرانيه خاصه
ان نعرف بان تكلفه الصواريخ الروسيه هي
همم باهضه الثمن تكلفه التصاريف الايرانيه
يعني قليله في لذلك يستطيع الروس شراء
الكثير من هذه الصواريخ واطلاقها بشكل
مكثف على الجانب الاوكراني لذلك اعتقد
الايرانيين قاموا همم الاقدام على هذه
الخطوه سوف يكون له رد كبير من الجانب
الاوروبي وكذلك الامريكي اذا ما حدث ذلك
يا دكتور اوف وتمكنت ايران من تزويد همم
روسيا ليس فقط كما يقول ضيف ابن مسيرات
وكذلك بالصواريخ البالستيه الى اي مدى هذا
قد يغير من معادله الازمه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه وقد يعمق خاصه
الانشقاقات داخل الدول التي تدعم كل طرف
في هذه المرحله
اه الصبح
يعني
المعدات
الاخرى الاصلاح الايراني
حتى ولو يعني
فالخطر هذه نحن ناخذ بالك نحن باستمرار
يعني بنعمل على تقويه الدفاع الجوي وتعال
بين كذلك
لتوفير همم كذلك طيران يعني طيران اف 16
احسن
من الجانب الروسي سواء كان مباشره من
الروس او باستعمال كذلك حوله من الدول
المنبوذه مثل
الجاني
في تصعيد مثل ذلك راح تكون عندنا حجه اخرى
عندنا يعني بصراحه يعني
وسيله همم
التفهيم يعني الجانب الغربي يعني لانه
عليهم فعلا هننتخب القرار بالنسبه
لتوفيرنا بالمعدات اخرى لان نحن طالبين من
زمان وبدرجه الرئيسيه طيران
بالذات الصواريخ لانه هو يعني من بعض
النواحي احسن من الدفاع الجوي الثابت
ولو ولو وفرت ايران حاولت ان توفر فهي
تعرض نفسها للخطر السياسي الكبير بان خلاص
يعني انتهى الموضوع بعدين ورخصات بالنسبه
للنوبه الايراني يعني وكل الامور وكل
الامنيات النظام
افكر بهذا المنطق بانها تفكر همم
لو سلمت هذه المسار السيارات وهذه
الصواريخ الروسيه قد تعرض نفس المزيد من
العقوبات قد تعرض نفسها المزيد من تازهم
على قاتها او انها فكر بمنطق اخر
يعني تعرف او تعي حجم المخاطره خاصه في ظل
هذه الخطوه وهي كانت تعي ايضا حتى حجم
المخاطره في ما يتعلق بالمسيرات ولكن هذا
الحديث ايضا قد يكون له رسائل الى الجانب
الاوروبي بمساله تصنيف الحرس الثوري كم
منظمه ارهابيه لانه الاوروبيين حتى وان لم
يصنفوا حتى هذه اللحظه ولكن هنالك اجتماع
خامس او جوله خامس سوف تناقش هذا الموضوع
بجديه لان الكثير من التقارير من التيمز
البريطانيه همم كثير من الدول ما زالت
راغب في ذلك وسوف يعلن في الجوله الخامسه
للتصويت عن ذلك فقد تكون جزء قد يكون جزء
من هذه الرسائل وهذه التصريحات الرسائل
الى الجانب الاوروبي ولكن بالمجمل همم
هنالك نقط يمكن اخذها بعين الاعتبار في
هذا المجال الاول نفود الروسي داخل
الايراني
نفود روسي كبير على ال- ال- ال- المتشددين
يعني في اوساط المتشددين ال- همم داخل
ايران فلذلك الايرانيين ايضا لا يمكنهم ان
للجانب الروسي لذلك نظرا لك تنسيقات
وهنالك نفوذ كبير يعني في الحقيقه من قبل
بوتين على النظام الايراني بشكل عام ايضا
النقطه الاخرى هي تتعلق بانهم يعون ايضا
تماما بانه لا توجد ثقه يعني في الجانب
الامريكي من قبل الجانب الايراني بمساله
المفاوضات النوويه وهذا ما يعطل هذه
المساله نقطه مثلا نقطه الحرس الثوري اللي
هم اساسا في عام 2015 عندما تم الاتفاق
على هذا عندما تم الاتفاق على اتفاق
النووي حاول النظام الايراني قدر الامكان
استبعاد اي ملف لائقه ليس له علاقه بالملف
النووي مثل الحرس الثوري بينما اليوم هم
يصرون على ضروره عدم تصنيف الحرس الثوري
كشارط اساس المفاوضات معنى هذا التناقض
دخل فيه الجانب الايراني لانهم اساسا لا
يعوم بهذه بالاطراف المفاوضه لا يثقون
بالاطراف المفاوضه ويعتقدون بان اي اي
اتفاق مع الجانب الاوروبي او الامريكي سوف
يكون اتفاق مؤقت وبالتالي سوف يتم
دقيقه لو سمحت لي تعليقا على وزير خارجيه
فرنسا التي قالت بان النظام الايراني يغرق
في حاله من الانكار ونظريه المؤامره كان
هذا التصريح اليوم هل تعتقد بان ايران همم
فعلا تغرق في نظريه المؤامره او انها
تستغل منطق المؤامره لخدمه حساباتها
ولخدمها
لعبه بكل تاكيد يعني هي ايران اساسا غارقه
بهذه النظريه منذ اليوم الاول لنجاح
الثوره الايرانيه في عام 79 وصول الخميني
الى السلطه لان هذه عقيده لدى النظام
الايراني بانهم يجب ان يحاربوا الغرب يجب
ان لا يتفقوا مع الغرب وهذه العقيده
تبناها ايضا ال ال
فلذلك هذا النظام يعني غارق بهذه النظريات
منذ اليوم الاول هذا جانب هنالك جانب اخر
وهو يعني يعتمد ربما يستغل ايضا مثلا على
المستوى الغربي هو هنالك عقيده على
المستوى الداخلي وبالمنطقه يستقيل هذه
النظريه لتنفيذ نوع من المؤسسات السياسات
الباحث في شان الايراني وشكرا كذلك لضيفي
من كافه دكتور الكسندر مديره ما احد همم
المعهد الوطني الاوكراني للدراسات
[موسيقى]